i'm not the biggest nfl fan in the world
not just because football's not my
favorite sport but also because the nfl
hates america and constantly disrespects
our flag and our entire country so i
don't really pay a whole lot of
attention to the nfl however my
producers have informed me that the nfl
is embarking on a new campaign called
inspire change
and i certainly think the nfl should
change and i don't
begrudge people the opportunity to
change their ways so in the hope that
the nfl will change
they are presenting me with this new ad
campaign and i can't wait
to react to it let me tell you about
where i'm from
where i'm from black neighborhoods are
devalued by 23 compared to white
neighborhoods 25 of the homes in
foreclosure are black owned just looking
at a house in the wrong neighborhood can
get you arrested our family has lived
here for five generations but we're the
first to own our own home
the nfl the national urban league are
fighting to protect and expand
affordable housing for all
because we all deserve a home no matter
where we're from okay now i see it's the
nfl doesn't want to change they just
want to become even more political and
tell all of us that we need to change
now you're getting it i am getting it so
the the argument here is that america's
very unjust because black homes are in
foreclosure among other things
that's kind of a strange example to use
that the black homes are in foreclosure
because that would be i think most
directly attributable to the people who
are not paying their mortgages so it's
not not exactly a social problem or some
problem of government oppression but
it's just the people who own the homes
can't pay their homes and they've got a
home that is too expensive for them or
for whatever reason they're not paying
their bills so hard to blame that on
other people
then they point to these other
social issues the black neighborhoods
have homes that are valued less than the
white neighborhoods and this undoubtedly
is a social problem but i'm not sure
exactly what the nfl wants the solution
to be i'm not saying it's fair
that
just using their statistics and taking
them for what they're worth and assuming
that they're true that the black
neighborhoods are are valued less than
the white neighborhoods but what's
supposed to happen is the government
supposed to pass a law and say black
neighborhoods can't be valued less than
white neighborhoods well white
neighborhoods have all sorts of
different values some neighborhood in
appalachia is going to have a much lower
value than a neighborhood outside of the
dc metro area in manhattan or something
like that so i understand that you can
look at these areas and and and try to
pass some new
law to to create equality but how's that
going to work in practice
and don't you think people are just
going to find a way around that too if
the issue is that there is a social
problem in america
that
people want to move into whiter
neighborhoods including
black people too including hispanic
people it's not just about white people
only wanting to live in white
neighborhoods if if that's the issue and
that's why the value is going up then it
seems like you've got to solve that
problem
but what is the nfl proposing the nfl
isn't proposing anything at all the nfl
is just presenting information implying
that this is evidence that america is a
horrible terrible place they're not
they're not solving anything they're
just whining and complaining and telling
you to feel bad about your country what
they're pushing here is not
they're obviously not pushing anything
about football and they're not even
pushing a political agenda because
they're not offering any policy
prescriptions they're pushing an
attitude
they're pushing a tone and a disposition
that america is bad and everything that
has gone in the past is really bad and
and the present that we're living in is
a crisis
and the future will be great if we
totally fundamentally transform america
and that's a very dangerous attitude
it's an unpatriotic attitude it's a
harmful attitude for all of us living
here now and it's just flat out
un-american exactly what you would
expect
from the national football league
[Music]
[Music]